noted bad guy
sacklers
the sackler family noted bad guys david
sackler said he and his family are going
to withdraw their pledge to pay 4.5
billion unless they get immunity from
lawsuits related to purdue pharma for
those that have not been following this
story
here's the breakdown
the sackler family is the family behind
purdue pharma purdue pharma was the
creator and distributor of opioid drugs
they would go to doctors and they would
basically say to the doctors you should
recommend this to your patients and they
have been accused of allegedly having
misleading marketing saying things that
were not true things around addiction or
the negative side effects etc
they made billions
billions of dollars in doing this and
there is an opioid crisis in america
that has ravaged on over 500 000 people
have died from the opioid crisis and so
obviously at some point
people came for the sacklers that came
for purdue pharma and there are lawsuits
from cities states uh i believe even at
the federal level et cetera going after
the sacklers and purdue pharma for this
nastiness
and the sacklers came out and they said
you know what you're right we're going
to pay 4.5 billion to victims
and they believed that they were going
to get immunity from all of the
lawsuits the investigations etc
and now all of a sudden a judge said
that wasn't part of the deal i don't
think that's happening and the sacklers
are now claiming that they're going to
retract they're going to renege on
something that they already said that
they were going to do
and so they said they're going to
withdraw that 4.5 billion pledge
now again the best business show we
respect you the audience we're not going
to feed you nonsense we're not going to
tell you what the mainstream talking
point is we get on our computers we have
our little
keyboards
and we start researching the best
business show research team is
undefeated on the internet undefeated
and what we found was the sacklers
and purdue pharma allegedly are not
going to pay anything out of pocket
what it appears and again this is all
allegations is that their 4.5 billion
dollar pledge which was the centerpiece
of this settlement
was going to come
from the future profit
of their business
it was not like they were going to take
4.5 billion of cash and give it to
people over the coming years it was
expected that they were actually going
to use the future profits
to pay it off on top of that if they
were to walk away from the american or
north american operations of purdue they
still would be allowed to be involved in
the international businesses and they
would be able to use some of those cash
flows as well to pay for this
so basically you've got a family
that has made what's estimated to be 12
to 13 billion dollars in profit from
oxycontin
that came from the manufacturer purdue
pharma according to forbes in 2019
and
starting in 2014 there's been 2 700
lawsuits and hundreds of thousands of
claims have been registered across 48
states local governments tribes
hospitals individuals and monitors of
infants
and david sackler who
to
be important usually the sacklers do not
appear in court but david sackler came
out and he was a board member at purdue
farmer and he said quote i think because
of the product we produce that has
helped millions of people has also been
associated with the opioid epidemic we
bear moral responsibility to try and
help and that's what the settlement is
designed to do
sounds like a good guy's statement
but let me explain to you how bad the
opioid crisis is 500 000 people died
from it
that would be almost two times the most
deaths ever
of u.s combat at war world war ii had
290 000 people die the civil war had 214
000 deaths world war one fifty thousand
vietnam almost fifty korean war thirty
three thousand iraq and afghanistan had
less than 5 000 deaths
according to this chart
the opioid crisis has
500 000 deaths
i don't know all the details i don't
claim to be an expert on this stuff but
what i do know is that there are
thousands tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of families
who lost a loved one because of this
situation
and when you start to talk about things
like misleading marketing and the
allegations that have been levied
against them
i don't think there is a price of what
could be paid that can make it right
on top of that when you talk about a
family that has
10 plus billion dollars based on what we
found online
you start to look at
the craziness
of these situations where people still
get
rich
according to this article the
uh
sackler's wealth includes 950 million
dollars in cash
a billion dollars in real estate
a billion in private equity investments
250 million dollars in art jewelry and
other collectibles
and they own a stake worth more than a
billion dollars in international drug
companies
it's pretty crazy what do you guys think
bad guys bad guys yeah bad guys they're
about to file uh for bankruptcy
supposedly after the settlement it was
estimated that it was going to be 10 to
12 billion when it first came out uh
but it doesn't really matter right like
they're them personally they're worth 10
billion
more people have died that i read
earlier uh then the heart of the uh when
aids was super when age was ravaging
this country really more people have
died than
500 000 then at the height of that right
per year here in the u.s so it's
obviously been uh extrapolated over the
last 10 to 12 years here and it's become
a real problem and the problem is that
they uh knew what they were doing they
knew that not only were these drugs
harmful but over time the effects of
these drugs were diminished on the on
the patients they were supposed to treat
right so if you keep taking these uh
these opioids are these oxycontin and
the other drugs they were offering over
time you're the you become more
dependent on them right you become not
only addicted but the value that they
bring to your body becomes less and less
over time so you need more of them they
knew all of this they intentionally
created courses in educational uh
material presented its doctors lobbied
for it in congress and did all these
things that forced uh their medicine on
hundreds of thousands of people and
millions of people that didn't need them
didn't want them and quite frankly uh
got addicted to them and died from them
it's terrible they lied to people to
make a profit
allegedly
allegedly
i want to be very clear on something we
being my brothers and i believe in the
american justice system we believe that
everyone should have their day in court
we believe that everyone should go in
front of a
their peers and a jury and figure it out
but the facts do not look very good for
these people
it does not look like there's some great
defense
it looks
again allegedly like what they're being
accused of happened
they should get their day in court
that's fine it appears they want to
settle
is 4.5 billion enough
if you uh
i'm all for like you said right the day
in court figure it out
whether you're telling the truth or not
like let everyone else decide on that if
you're paying a five billion dollar
settlement that seems like you might be
somewhat guilty that's that's a lot of
money just to fork over for a settlement
for uh claiming that you still might be
in a center it wasn't as bad as you say
but when you look at it from a per
patient number or per death number five
hundred thousand people died it's like
seven thousand dollars per person i
think which is you know the families
that essentially does uh nothing for
them so from a pure dollar standpoint of
like what the impact that people are
going to get it's not significant uh the
top number seems super high but they're
going to file for bankruptcy the
family's still going to be super wealthy
uh and the affected families aren't
going to get much of a payment in return
4.5 billion with five hundred thousand
people it's nine thousand dollars a
person i'm pretty close
yeah
yeah joey math all right
drug dealers that's what it is it's
legal drug dealing obviously i mean it's
a drug and they're dealing they're
manufacturing they're distributing it
it's legal drug dealing so uh what is it
can ask one question real quick but
how do we think about and john maybe you
answer this
there's i don't know
hundred thousands
maybe millions of people behind bars in
our country for selling a plant
and these people made billions that is
not in their ivory tower
with 12 billion dollars
a plant that's now legal in almost half
the states in the country when you bring
those two together
why because they wear suits and ties and
wear it cologne
and these people didn't
what's the difference he definitely
wears cologne
that picture reeked from here
he wears salmon pants too probably um i
mean what is the difference
right there i i don't know what what is
the incarceration hold on let's see u.s
incarceration
for drugs
it is estimated uh every 25 seconds
someone in america is arrested for drug
possession every 25 seconds someone in
america this is from 2018. that's a wide
range though every 25 seconds someone in
america is arrested for drug possession
the number of americans arrested for
possession has tripled since 1980
reaching 1.3 million arrests per year in
2015. 1.3 million per year are arrested
in 2015 for drug possession that's six
times the number of arrests for drug
sales the possession
is worse than the drug sales in terms of
the number one fifth of the incarcerated
population or about half a million
individuals serving time in 2018
was for drug charges and another 1.15
million people are on probation and
parole for drug-related offenses half a
million people the number of people who
died in the opioid pandemic or uh
epidemic pandemic what are you going to
call it i guess epidemic 500 000 people
died from the opioid epidemic
almost 500 000 people in 2018 that were
incarcerated about one-fifth of every
incarcerated person in america
is for drugs that's a general statement
though because that's a that's a wide
range drugs right some of those people
are probably in for opioids or
more serious stuff than uh just
marijuana meth
yeah
i'm saying
i'm saying i'm just saying i'm saying
all the trucks but my point is
here's my point is
it's less about
what are they there for
we've put half a million people right
now and then another million plus on
probation and other kind of supervisory
um conditions
for drugs
and what appears to be
one of not the largest but one of the
largest drug manufacturers dealers
however you want to describe it in
america
is got 12 billion and they're chilling
and they're basically again what appears
to be they're dangling a settlement out
in front of people saying we'll give you
the cash but we want full immunity so
what is that's the part that i think
you're like listen where's the justice
system there is it just that rich people
these people are going to have 10
billion dollars and pay is it just that
rich people get to say that why why
can't the drug dealer that's arrested on
the street corner say i you know listen
i was wrong no problem
i'll pay ten thousand dollars but i want
immunity
why don't they get to do
that hey guys thanks so much for
watching that clip of the best business
show make sure you like and subscribe to
the channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com so that you can
get an account we can get after it
you